إيران بلد أقوى
بكثير من أي دولة أخرى في
هذه المنطقة ، وحلفاء إيران في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة أقوياء جدًا ، لذا فإن شن حرب أو
ضربة ضد إيران لا
يمكن تحقيقه حقًا لأن الرد سيكون
شديد الوطأة
وهؤلاء  البلدان في هذه المنطقة التي لديها
قواعد أمريكية
ستدمر ولا أحد يريد ألا
آخذ هذه التهديدات ، ولا أعتقد أن أي شخص في إيران
يأخذ هذه التهديدات على محمل الجد ،
لكنه يضر بصورة الولايات المتحدة فقط في إيران ،
والإيرانيون يريدون الصفقة و  كما
قلتم سابقًا ،
يحتاج الإيرانيون إلى الصفقة لأنهم بحاجة إلى تخفيف
الضغط على الإيرانيين العاديين ،
لكنك أيضًا على صواب في أن
حملة الضغط الأقصى للضغط الأقصى
لم تنجح وأن محاولات ترامب
لجلب إيران إلى ركبتيه باءت بالفشل وما
حدث في
إيران  حقق البرنامج النووي تقدمًا أعظم ، وحقق
حلفاء إيران في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
، علاقات أقوى لإيران مع
روسيا والصين أفضل بكثير
، وهذا
على المدى الطويل.  سيجعل
نفوذ الولايات المتحدة في هذه المنطقة
وقدرة الولايات المتحدة على إيذاء إيران
تتناقص ، لذا فإن الشيء الذكي الذي يجب على
الولايات المتحدة فعله
هو إيجاد حل معقول.